[Music]
what's going on fam it's Monte Carlo and
do you know what the internet is chock
full of besides porn and the Kardashians
opinions BAE we all have one especially
when it comes to food but who's got the
brightest opinion of them all my boss
Gordon Ramsay who has something to say
about the craziness you've been sending
him on Twitter let's see what the
Internet's cooked up today okay Wow look
at this
wide open bag of suck it is literally
tuna with mayo mixed in why would you do
this to yourself who eats this crap you
know what this dish needs help Ramsey
Redemption let's do it
you want to impress your tinder date
make them a beautiful composed salad
with jarred tuna that's step one does
this look like something you'd serve to
your cat no this is good stuff all right
first things first we're gonna elevate
this tuna by adding some heat to it and
that means pickled jalapenos like look
this is a mandolin you can slice a
jalapeno with your knife and show off
your perfect knife skills or you can be
a complete lazy bum like me isn't that
gorgeous
no you can see through it the whole
thing is hot that's no joke we are gonna
pickle this jalapeno it's a quick pickle
which means it takes no time at all and
what that's gonna do it's gonna add
acidity it's gonna add heat to your
salad it's gonna make it perfection
equal parts water and white distilled
vinegar you're gonna add a pinch of salt
because you always add a pinch what it's
a pinch three fingers babe
and then a touch of sweetness because it
adds that I like to use honey if you
don't have honey you can also use sugar
okay looking dissolve the honey and then
pick up glove always alright pick up
these jalapenos we'll drop them in the
pickling juice and we're just gonna
bring it to a gentle simmer and let them
sit step 2 we're gonna make a fabulous
dressing yes you could buy dressing at
the grocery store but this one is so
much easier it's yummy and hello it's
quick we're going to start with olive
oil vinegar some garlic that's been
mashed into a paste a touch of salt now
here's a trick to dressing one part
vinegar to three to four parts oil we're
gonna start with a little touch of the
garlic some salt and I'm gonna use some
lemon why lemon and vinegar because I'd
like to combine vinegars and acids that
way it gives you depth of flavor you're
gonna get the juice of a whole lemon
look at my Mike Tyson strength are you
sick of my 80s references now it's very
important when you're making dressing
that you taste it before you add the oil
you want it to be bright acidic
have enough salt in it salt elevator
alright we're gonna drizzle the olive
oil in little by little and then we're
gonna emulsify emulsification is just a
fancy word for the oil given the vinegar
a nice big hug
don't pour all the oil in at once a
little more acid and we are ready to go
dressing done how fast was that so fast
let's check on our pickles whoo you see
that beautiful steam ready to go they're
steaming up we're gonna take the
jalapeno slices out of the pickling
liquid all right and then we're gonna
pour the pickling liquid into the jar do
you see how perfect that was come on
done pickles that was so fast right you
don't even have to deal with parking at
the grocery store amazing step 3 now
that we have made our dressing we are
going to put together the greens why
greens in the salad because it's begging
for it it's nutty it's peppery it's
gonna cut through all of the fat in the
olive oil Italian parsley it's gonna add
earthiness to the arugula put it all use
some edamame which is a soybean that's
been cooked actually if you buy it in
the frozen food aisle it's already
cooked we've just gotta warm it up
I like to add lemon thyme and go ahead
and take all the leaves off now when
you're using lemon thyme or anytime for
that matter don't just like pick the
leaves out one by one
just go against the grain like you're
petting the kitty there you go BAM now
it's time to dress the greens
please don't actually put dressing on
your greens that's wrong dress the bowl
like so dress the bowl boom and then you
toss the greens and that way they still
look good you know my girls wearing too
much makeup you don't want your greens
to look like that alright salt always
from above
let's add more color to this salad with
a radish radish is a fabulous
now you're gonna keep your radish fresh
by putting it in some ice water it's
gonna keep it nice and crisp otherwise
you're gonna get a wibbly-wobbly radish
ain't nobody got time for that
okay how pretty that look at this this
is the prettiest thing lie to me it's so
great all right moving on
scallions are gonna give you a nice
pungent bite so we're just rockin oh I
love the sound of that that's that's
good enough we are also gonna put the
scallions in ice water to keep them
fresh fresh is the name of the game and
it comes to salad there's nothing for
this tuna to hide behind so your
ingredients have to be good have you
guys seen this before this is a Persian
cucumber use a Persian cucumber or an
English cucumber right we're gonna toss
these again and that dressing have you
guys seen these mushrooms before they're
enoki mushrooms we're gonna take off
this woody end and then look at this how
pretty are these gonna be on our plate
they look like little alien ears put
these to the side we'll plate these
later do you know what these are
sardines it gives you depth of flavor
it's savory so we're going to chop these
into a paste and we're gonna add it to
our tuna okay
we're gonna take our sardines and we are
gonna mix them into our tuna don't break
up the tuna be gentle about it okay
now that we have 158 components ready to
go let's redeem this dish we've got our
greens
they've been dressed we're going for
that gangbusters Instagram shot we're
gonna add some of our incredible radish
slices to give it pops of color our
edamame beans throughout our slices of
cucumber and then we're going to finish
[Music]
and then we're going to very gently
place our tuna just a little here and
there okay all right look at that it's
looking gorgeous guys I am winning the
game today all right black sesame seeds
look how gorgeous that is
finally these pickles are officially
pickles this is going to add that
incredible heat it's gonna cut right
through and give incredible personality
to this tuna that's what you eat for
lunch this dish has been redeemed look
at this beauty okay this looks so much
better than that dish that Gordon called
cat vomit let those words about this
salad ain't gonna happen
this dish really moves me thanks so much
for hanging out if you've got a dish
that needs Redemption just submit it
with the hashtag Ramsey Redemption
Gordon would love to talk trash and I
would love to try and fix it thanks for
joining us today and make sure to hit
subscribe so you can watch more fun
Gordon Ramsay videos I'm just gonna cool
it anyone anyone anyone in their 40s
here now okay
[Laughter]